I'm will Lewis I'm a principal program
manager with the Microsoft translator
team and recently we had a group of
students who were being hosted at the
University of Washington a group of
Chinese students in particular trainings
undergraduate students and they were
visiting now at the University of
Washington for a few days they brought
them over here to MSR for a brief time
to introduce them to the research that
mike is being done at Microsoft Research
and so we actually had them come to a
talk that I was giving on what we do on
speech translation so the translator a
live feature is the feature allows you
to create a what we call a virtual room
where people can have conversations in
multiple languages so one of the ways we
host this is through powerpoints so
using the presentation translator so on
the screen as part of this add-in it
actually shows a QR code that people can
use to join from their own devices and
so what happens is while I'm talking
they will see the transcripts on the
screen if I choose to have them on the
screen and then they will also see the
transcripts on their local devices in
the language of choice and so when I
talk you hear the Mandarin actually
being spoken as I talk so Yeong Washu
Allah - ooh ho ho $18 Washu owada put'em
ha I can speak while showing a
PowerPoint deck and will show the
transcripts on the screen and at the
same time it'll allow people to join
from their own devices so when John
asked his question you see the
transcript of what he's asking on the
screen in English not in Mandarin the
students were completely amazed by this
feature where they saw the transcripts
of me talking they were showing up on
the screen then they were seeing them on
their own devices and then they were
seeing in them and Chinese script as I
was talking and then at one point I
turned on the audio so they could hear
the Mandarin being spoken as I was
speaking English so this feature is
particularly important in the classroom
because it allows teachers or lecturers
or whatever to give a talk or give a
discussion in the class in their native
language so for students who are
non-native speakers
or maybe our recent immigrants or maybe
visiting here maybe they're visiting
scholars for instance they don't know
the language well they have access then
to the content that's being discussed
because they could see the transcripts
in their own language